It's my first time on the podcast, I want to say. I was expecting a C++ podcast, but it's so much more than that. When I think of C++ shops, I think of Google, I think of Microsoft, I think of Adobe, I think of Bloomberg. Some companies have been divesting, they've been trying to maybe move to Rust or have their own competitor like Carbon. Yeah, Transmeda. It was a hot startup in the 90s. It was a company that made an X-D6 chip that competed with Intel and EMD and VIA. Mike's keynote was eye-opening for a little people, me included.
这是我第一次参加这个播客，我想说。我本来期待的是一个C++播客，但它远不止于此。当我想到C++公司时，我会想到谷歌、微软、Adobe和彭博。有些公司一直在剥离业务，他们可能在尝试转向Rust，或者拥有像Carbon这样的竞争对手。是的，Transmeta。那是90年代一家热门的初创公司。它制造了一种与英特尔、AMD和VIA竞争的x86芯片。Mike的主题演讲让很多人大开眼界，包括我。
That is up there with Sean Parents, C++ Now, keynote from like 2012 or 2013. A normal struct and automatically converting it to an SOA layout using reflection even in sales plus 17. The voice in my head is like, blah-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-ha. Yes, the message, of course, is be angry. That's what we're saying. And also, you said you're Canadian-eyes, or you've been very mean to me today. I will not forget that. Please use a monospace font. Hi, my name's Jeff.
这和Sean Parent在2012年或2013年左右的C++ Now主题演讲处于同一水平。一个普通的结构体，即使在C++17中，也可以通过反射自动转换为SOA布局。我脑子里的声音就像是，blah-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-ha。是的，信息当然是：要愤怒。这就是我们要说的。而且，你说你是加拿大人，或者你今天对我非常刻薄。我不会忘记的。请使用等宽字体。嗨，我叫Jeff。
What do you want to know? Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 259, recorded on September 24, 2025. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we interview live from NDC Techtown 2025 in Kongsburg, Norway, both Victoria Romeo and J.F. Bastion. we talk about their respective talks, C++, training, and more. All right, folks, we're here. It's technically day three for Bryce and I of NDC Techtown, but it is day one for most folks because the conference has started today.
你想知道什么？欢迎来到ADSP播客，第259集，录制于2025年9月24日。我叫Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人Bryce一起，在挪威康斯贝格的NDC Techtown 2025现场采访Vittorio Romeo和J.F. Bastion。我们讨论了他们各自的演讲、C++、培训等等。好了，各位，我们到了。对Bryce和我来说，这在技术上是NDC Techtown的第三天，但对大多数人来说是第一天，因为会议今天才开始。
We have finished our Kuta trainings, which you heard last episode a week ago as we chatted about that in the lobby of the hotel. And now we are here at the tail end of day one. had our first day of talks. Bryce is going to be interviewing Vittorio Romeo, folks. You've heard about him on the podcast. We've never interviewed him.
我们已经完成了Kuta培训，你们在一周前的上一集中听到了我们在酒店大堂聊到这个。现在我们处于第一天的尾声。我们进行了第一天的演讲。Bryce要采访Vittorio Romeo，各位。你们在播客上听说过他。我们从未采访过他。
He is the author and behind many projects. The one that I bring up the most, as I've told Vittorio, is Camamilla, the compiler, the compiler, the template error compiler reducer. Actually, that's a terrible explanation. But listen, I've had a couple of Carlsbergs. It's actually true. Wait, we're in Norway now and we're drinking Carlsberg? That's the beer of Denmark.
他是许多项目的作者和幕后推手。正如我告诉Vittorio的，我提到最多的是Camamilla，那个编译器，那个模板错误编译器简化器。实际上，这是一个糟糕的解释。但听着，我喝了几杯嘉士伯。这其实是真的。等等，我们现在在挪威，我们在喝嘉士伯？那是丹麦的啤酒。
What's going on here? Anyways, we're here with Vitorio. I'm handing the mic over to Bryce. He's headed out tonight, so we only have Bryce for another two hours minus the, or two and a half hours minus the time for the C++ quiz. Bryce is going to interview Vittorio. Hopefully Vittorio introduces himself for the listener. Here we go. Yeah, Vittorio, I mean, how would you introduce yourself?
这到底是怎么回事？总之，我们和Vittorio在一起。我把麦克风交给Bryce。他今晚要出发，所以我们只有不到两个半小时的时间，减去C++测验的时间。Bryce将采访Vittorio。希望Vittorio能为听众介绍一下自己。我们开始吧。是的，Vittorio，我是说，你会如何介绍自己？
I feel like you've done so many varied things. You're a trainer, you've worked in FinTech, and you also work in game, the game design space. I mean, how would you introduce yourself? Last time I checked, you work at Bloomberg. Do you no longer work? No. How long have you not? So wait, the last time I checked.
我觉得你做过很多不同的事情。你是一名培训师，你在金融科技领域工作过，你还在游戏设计领域工作。我是说，你会如何介绍自己？我上次查看时，你在彭博工作。你不再在那里工作了吗？不。你离开多久了？等等，我上次查看时。
JF Bastion just showed up. This is the thing. J.F. Bryce said like literally three minutes ago. Oh, J.F. and Chandler left. Chandler from Google and J.F. from some startup that we don't know what it does. I have to read you this text exchange from J.F. I, I text J.F. I asked him where he is.
J.F. Bastion刚出现。就是这样。J.F.，Bryce在三分钟前还说：“哦，J.F.和Chandler走了。”来自谷歌的Chandler和来自我们不知道做什么的某家初创公司的J.F.。我必须读一下J.F.发给我的短信。我给J.F.发短信，问他在哪里。
He says he went to the root, drop my bag in the room, coming back now. And I said, have you seen Chandler? And he said, he's not in my room. We're clearly J.F. understood that that's not what I meant. So, wait, wait, well, all right. We'll get you introducing Victoria in a moment. This is going to take some time, folks. So I know you're young, but have you seen the Pink Panther, the movie?
他说他去了房间，把包放下，现在正回来。我说，你看到Chandler了吗？他说，他不在我房间。显然J.F.明白我指的不是那个。所以，等等，好吧。我们一会儿再让你介绍Vittorio。这需要一些时间，各位。我知道你很年轻，但你看过《粉红豹》那部电影吗？
I have not seen the Pink Panther. We haven't seen the movie. We know who he is, though. With Peter Sellers, right? No, we don't know the actors. We know what the Pink Panther is. That's it. We're born in the 90s, okay?
我没看过《粉红豹》。我们没看过那部电影。不过我们知道他是谁。是Peter Sellers演的，对吧？不，我们不知道演员。我们知道《粉红豹》是什么。就这样。我们是90后，好吗？
So there's one of the Pink Panthers, because there's multiple of them. I have him on VHS, if you want to borrow them any day. Peter Sellers is in a hotel, and he goes in, and he sees someone with the dog. I have the microphone. So he sees someone with a dog, and he's like, does your dog bite? And the person answers, no. And so Peter Sellers, the Inspector Cluzzo, comes in, and he goes to pet the dog. and then he gets bit by the dog
所以《粉红豹》有很多部，因为有好几部。如果你想借的话，我随时有VHS录像带。Peter Sellers在一家酒店里，他走进去，看到一个人带着狗。我有麦克风。所以他看到一个人带着狗，他说，你的狗咬人吗？那个人回答，不。于是Peter Sellers，也就是Clouseau探长，走过去想摸那只狗，结果被狗咬了。
and he goes to the person and says I thought you said your dog didn't bite and then the person replies that's not my dog and so fairly often you and I have exchanges where you ask a question and I answer the question you asked
然后他走到那个人面前说，我以为你说你的狗不咬人。那个人回答说，那不是我的狗。所以，你和我经常会有这样的交流：你问一个问题，我回答你问的问题。
did you bring your VHS tapes on your international move to Japan I did yes but first last time I checked Vitorio was working at Bloomberg and at one point I mean you can fill in the details but this is what I know you were an engineer at Bloomberg and then you transitioned to an internal kind of trainer at Bloomberg and you were in charge of kind of C++ education I know that there's a guild system I'm not super
你搬到日本时带了你的VHS录像带吗？我带了，是的。但首先，我上次查看时，Vittorio在彭博工作，而且在某个时候，我是说你可以补充细节，但我知道的是，你是彭博的一名工程师，然后你转型为彭博内部的培训师，负责C++教育。我知道那里有一个公会系统，我不太熟悉，因为我从未在那里工作过，但我记得我们有过一次谈话，你转型到了你梦想的角色之一，负责彭博的教育，但你不再在彭博了，我看到是Romeo.training，希望这是一个网址，也许不是。总之，我们要把麦克风交给Vittorio，他可以——或者Bryce正在检查它是否真的是一个可以访问的域名。介绍一下你自己，告诉我们你的工作经历以及你现在在做什么，因为显然你已经离开了彭博。谢谢，谢谢。
familiar because I've never worked there but I remember having a conversation where you had kind of like transition to one of your dream roles of like being in charge of education of Bloomberg but you no longer at Bloomberg and I saw it was Romeo dot training which hopefully is a URL maybe it's not anyways, we're going to hand the mic to Vittorio, and he can, or Bryce is checking if it actually is a domain that you can go to. Introduce yourself and tell us about your work history and what you're up to now, because clearly you've moved on from Bloomberg. Thank you, thank you.
这是我第一次参加这个播客，我想说。我本来期待的是一个C++播客，但它远不止于此。所以这非常有趣，谢谢你们邀请我。是的，你说得对。过去10年我一直在彭博。前半段，我主要从事低延迟、高吞吐量、高性能后端的软件工程，包括我们的微服务基础设施、市场数据分析，然后我逐渐自然地转向了培训。
So it's my first time on the podcast, I want to say. I was expecting a C-Pas-Past podcast, but it's so much more than that. So it is very interesting, and thank you for having me. Yeah, you're correct. I used to be a Bloomberg for the past 10 years. And the first half, I kind of did software engineering on low latency, high-reput, high-performance, backends, including our microservice infrastructure, market auto-data analytics, and then I switched gradually organically to training.
我觉得我们在教工程师C++的方式上存在差距。没有什么关于现代C++的内容，没有什么关于新标准的内容。所以我从一些小事开始。我意识到这是我擅长且真正喜欢的事情。所以经过多年，它成了我的主要关注点和主要工作。我负责C++教育，特别是现代部分。我今年9月停止在彭博工作，所以非常非常近。所以，是的，现在我正在尝试开启这个创业项目，我将进行独立的咨询、承包和培训。
I felt like there was a gap in the way that we were teaching engineers C++. There was nothing on motorcycles plus, nothing on, you know, the newer standards. So I kind of started with something small. I realized it was something I was good at and I really liked. So over the course of multiple years, it became my main focus on my main job. and I was in charge of the civil class education, especially the modern part. I stopped working at Bloomberg this September, so very, very, it is very recent. So, yeah, right now I'm trying to start this venture where I'm going to do independent consulting, contracting, and training.
到目前为止，这对我是新的领域，所以我有一些客户，主要是指导个人。能够一次专注于一个人，看着他们将C风格的代码转换成更现代、更安全的代码，这真的很有成就感。所以看到这些非常有意义，但这对我来说是非常新的领域。所以我正在探索，看看进展如何。但回答你的问题，是的，我一直在做很多非常不同的事情。我觉得把它们联系在一起的是我对C++和优秀软件工程永恒的、热情的爱。所以我涉足了非常不同的领域，游戏开发、金融、培训，但一直都是C++和漂亮的代码。这可能就是原因。
So far as new territory for me, so I have a few clients here and there, mostly individuals that are mentoring. And it's really rewarding to be able to focus on one person at a time and, you know, seeing them transform their sea-like. code into something a bit more, you know, modern and safe. So it's really rewarding to see that, but it's very new territory for me. So I'm exploring around seeing how it goes. But to answer your question, like, yes, I've been doing a lot of very different things. I feel like the thing that ties them all together is my undying, passionate love for C++ and good software engineering. So doubled in very different domains, game development, finance, training, but it's all of always been C++ and nice code. That is probably the time.
好的，我有两个问题，然后我会让Bryce从这里开始提问，但我非常好奇。所以，如果我们必须按C++的使用情况来对公司进行排名，而且当我提到使用时，我也指参加委员会会议的情况，彭博绝对能排进前10名，甚至可能排进前5名。我不太清楚，但重点是彭博是主要公司之一。我也想到它，Bryce说是第三名。我们现在不是在谈论JavaScript。等等，你真的有前五或前十的名单吗？是的，我知道，因为这很容易找到。
All right, so I've got two questions, and then I'll let Bryce ask the questions from here, but I am very curious. So, if we had to rank corporations by their C++ usage and also kind of, when I say usage, I also mean like attendance at committee meetings, Bloomberg definitely makes the top 10 and maybe makes the top five. I don't really know, but the point being is Bloomberg is one of the kind of major companies. I also think about it number three Bryce says number three We're not talking about Java strip right now Wait, do you actually have like the top five or ten? Yeah, I know because it's easy to find
你只需要去美国国家机构，看看顶级买家。C++委员会，是的。好吧，你不是在谈论数百万行代码。总之，重点是，彭博名列前茅。当我想到C++公司时，我会想到谷歌、微软、Adobe、彭博。总之，我的第一个问题是，你在彭博负责教育多久了？我的第二个问题是，培训这些前沿公司是什么感觉？因为你知道，你使用C++不仅是几年，而是几十年。培训并让人们——我不知道你是从98到11还是11到20——那是什么感觉？因为我想你一定有非常有趣的，我不想说是战争故事，但只是关于那种教育过程的故事。是的，所以我觉得在彭博培训真的很有趣，因为你会遇到极其多样化的人群、技能组合和资历。你可能会遇到超级熟练的工程师，他精通金融，但10年来没有从C语言中走出来。或者你可能会遇到做过很多函数式编程但从未在C++中做过的人。所以你会得到一个非常困难、多样化的受众。这确实让它变得有趣，因为每个人都有不同的背景。所以培训的互动性和乐趣肯定更高，因为你可以更好地了解人们，他们会分享他们的背景，并通过从他们的角度看待培训来以某种方式做出贡献。
You just go to the U.S. national body and you look at the top byors The C++'s committee, yeah Okay, you're not talking about like millions of lines of code Anyways, the point being, Bloomberg is up there as like When I think of C++ shops, I think of Google, I think of Microsoft, I think of Adobe, I think of Bloomberg, anyways, the point my first question is how long were you in charge of education at Bloomberg and my second question is what is it like training one of these kind of frontier companies in terms of you know you've been using
这很有趣，但也绝对具有挑战性。我教过现代C++ 11、14、17和20，所以我几乎涵盖了整个范围，我们提供了几门课程，这样人们就有了一条学习路径，可以逐渐学习越来越新的标准。对于问题的第一部分，
c++ not just for years but for decades what is it like training and like getting people i don't know if you're going from 98 to 11 or 11 to 20 uh what does that like because i imagine you have very interesting i don't want to say war stories but just stories to tell about that kind of education process yeah so i feel like training at bloomberg was really interesting because you get an extremely diverse set of people, skill sets, seniority. And you might have the super skilled engineer that knows everything about finance but hasn't moved from C in 10 years. Or you might have the person that has been doing a lot of functional programming
我觉得彭博对C++的未来投入巨大，而其他一些公司正在退缩。例如，你提到了谷歌。是的，没错。有些公司一直在剥离业务。他们一直在尝试转向Rust，或者拥有像Carbon这样的竞争对手。彭博仍然坚信C++的未来。
but never done that in C++. So you get a very difficult, varied audience. So it does make it interesting because everybody has a different background. So the interactivity and the fun of the training is certainly higher as you get to get people to get a know better and they will kind of share their background and contribute in some way by, you know, having the training scene from their perspective,
他们积极参与标准制定，试图解决或缓解——我不知道正确的词是什么——安全问题，以及任何让C++在当今相比其他语言吸引力稍逊的东西。他们拥有庞大的代码库，并不打算迁移到其他东西。他们打算随着标准的增长继续维护和升级。所以我感觉他们是这个领域非常大的参与者。
which is something that is interesting, but definitely challenging. I've taught from MotorC++ Plus 11, 14, 17, and 20, so I've done pretty much all the spectrum, and we offered them in, you know, several courses so that people have this learning path, they could gradually learn newer and newer standards. For the first part of the question,
这解释了为什么他们投入大量资源到标准委员会，并保持他们的代码库为C++。好吧，我是说，我们刚才提到——可能是一周前了，但无论我们什么时候举行Roku聚会，他们都在展示，我们不能谈论他们演讲的具体细节，但他们展示了一些Roku代码，其中row代表Roku，STD代表标准命名空间。我凭记忆回顾了所有不同类型的插入、字母、SL标准库。彭博是最著名的开源其许多工具和标准库的公司之一。有很多演讲，无论是在众多的C++会议上，展示了其中的不同方面。所以是的，彭博以开源其内部企业标准库而闻名，是的，总之，听到关于转型的消息非常有趣。最后一个问题是什么？然后我要——因为我看得出Bryce有一些问题。
I feel like Bloomberg is heavily invested, in the future of C++, while some other companies are backing down a little bit. You mentioned Google, for example. Google has been... Yes, exactly. Some companies have been divesting. They have been trying to maybe move to rust or have their own competitor like carbon. Bloomberg still heavily believes in C++'s future.
最后一个问题是，你说到C++ 20，那是彭博官方最新的版本吗？是的，我们过去有一个带有特定标准的经过审查的编译器套件，我相信我在公司时我们最终到了C++ 20，但有些团队在其他团队之前就开始尝试C++ 23了。这是一个非常，怎么说呢，团队有很大的决策权。所以如果他们有充分的理由，他们可以在其他团队之前转向新标准。但20是官方最新的。很高兴知道。
They are actively working in the standard to try and solve or mitigate. I don't know what the right word is. The safety issues and whatever makes C++ plus a bit less attractive nowadays compared to other languages. and they do have a huge code base which they don't intend to migrate to something else. They intend to keep maintaining and keep upgrading as a standard growth. So I feel like a very big player in this area
好的，我把麦克风交给Bryce。好吧，实际上，我们和Vittorio这位培训师交谈的时机非常凑巧，因为我们刚刚完成了两个研讨会。在NVIDIA工作的一整年里，在推广和教育材料方面有很大的推动力，我一直在做更多的培训和演讲，并开发培训材料。Connor，这是你第一次教授课程，你完成了我们C++课程的前半部分。我想我有一个问题要问你，作为第一次培训师，你的体验如何？这太累人了。我喜欢做演讲，因为它们最多一个小时或90分钟。八小时的培训日。我不知道是因为我内向，还是因为我喜欢坐在多个显示器前用RGB键盘，但八小时真的——我是说，我甚至没有（你知道）讲满八小时。我只讲了半天。但它太累人了。而且我认为，部分原因是我并没有完全自己创建素材。我觉得如果我专门设计了一门课程，按照我想要教授的方式，并专门针对我想要教授的内容，那会大不相同。但从一群人那里获取策划的内容，然后不得不教授那些你并没有完全掌握的内容，
and it explains why they put a lot of resources into the standard committee and keeping their code base in C++ plus. Well, I mean, we were just mentioning, I mean, it might have been a week ago now, but whenever we had the Roku meetup, they were presenting, we can't talk about the specific
比如，我不知道，有时我看着预览屏幕，看着解决方案是在下一张幻灯片上，还是有另一张幻灯片显示该怎么做？当你做自己的演讲时，你永远不会遇到这种情况。或者至少按照我做演讲的方式，我已经排练了几次。这几乎是信手拈来。所以，你几乎——我不知道。排练听起来很糟糕，因为它听起来不像那种方式，但你练习了。所以你知道接下来会发生什么。
specifics of their presentation, but they showed some roasted code, which was row for Roku and STD for the standard namespace. And I went through off the top of my memory of all the different kind of insert, letter, SL standard libraries. And Bloomberg is one of the most well-known kind of open-sourcing, a lot of their tooling and their standard libraries. And there's a lot of talks, whether it's at, you know, just a plethora of C++ conference showing different aspects of that. So yeah, Bloomberg is very well-known for kind of open-sourcing, their internal corporate standard library and yes anyways very interesting to hear about the transitioning what is the last question then I'm gonna I'm at because I can tell Bryce got some
所以你永远不会觉得，我是在说正确的话吗？或者我需要在这个点上花更多时间吗？重点是，我想我可能会爱上培训。但如果我要爱上一门培训课程，我基本上必须从零开始做所有的材料，这……你是在自愿承担。是的，Bryce说，哦，你只是自愿？不，我不是自愿做那个。
questions what is the what is the you said up to C plus plus 20 is that the the latest that Bloomberg's at officially yes like we we used to have like a vetted compiler suite with a certain standard and I do believe that we ended up at 6 plus 20 while I was still in the company but there were teams also dabbling with S Plus 23 before other teams. It's a very, let's say teams have a lot of decision power. So if they had a good reason, too, they could move to standards even before the other teams. But 20 was officially the latest one. Good to know.
我不一定……那不是我想在职业生涯中采取的方向。但总之，我对培训师有了更大的赞赏。我假设你会创建你所有的内容，所以希望这会有助于培训过程。但总之，这非常累人。我认为90分钟，在我看来，是完美的演讲长度。30分钟太短了，简直不可思议。
All right, I'm handing the mic to Bryce. Well, it's actually, it's a very fortuitous timing that we're talking to Vittorio, a trainer, because we just did two workshops. whole year at work at nVIDIA there's been a big push on outreach and education of material and i've been doing a lot more training and talks and developing training material and uh connor this was your first time teaching a course you did the first half of our c plus plus course i guess i'm kind of i got a question for you which is what was it like as a first time trainer what was your experience it was exhausting i love giving talks because they're an hour or 90
45分钟还可以。一个小时也行。90分钟是完美的。八小时简直是疯了。但是的，这是我第一次，所以。我认为你讲到90分钟时会失去听众。JF，你做过培训吗？我是说，我假设当你在Woven时，你可能负责一些培训，比如，弄清楚培训和教育。那可能是你……我们两次抢话了。J.F.从未正式接受过采访。你上次来的时候……哦，不是采访。是的，是的，没有采访。你上次来的时候是亮点之一。
minutes max. An eight-hour training day. I don't know if it's the introvert in me, if it's the guy that likes to be in front of multiple monitors with an RGP keyboard, but just like eight hours is, I mean, I didn't even, you know, I wasn't speaking for the full eight hours. I only did half the day. But it was exhausting. And I think also too, it's partly because I did not create the source material entirely myself, I feel like if I had designed a course specifically the way I wanted to teach it and specifically geared towards the things that I wanted to teach, it would have been much different. But taking curated content from, you know, a bunch of folks and then having to teach content that's not, you know, you didn't, you don't know it inside and out in terms
播客的亮点，我们经常提到它，各位。我们将在三周、两周后在C++ Under the Sea见到Sean Parent。JF也在那里。我想那是那三部分剪辑的第一部分，第二部分和第三部分只是和Sean在一起，怎么说呢？是一个过剩，一个大杂烩。没有词可以形容发生了什么。J.F.在那里进进出出。我想我们有Phil Nash，有你，我们几乎有当时每一个C++播客的代表。总之，大家可能记得也可能不记得你。你得介绍一下自己，J.F.。我是说，你搬到了Woven，也就是丰田。我们之前谈到了普锐斯。他说那不是他的错。他其实没那么说。
of like, I don't know, like sometimes I was looking at the preview screen, looking at, is the solution on the next slide or is there another slide showing like what to do? And you never have that when you're giving your own talk. Like, or at least the way that I give talks, I've rehearsed it a couple times. It's almost like off the back of whatever. Like, so you, it's almost, I don't know. Rehears sounds bad because it sounds like, you know, not the way, but you practice. And so you know what's coming.
我只是在客气。那可能是他的错，各位。但在那之前，他在苹果。现在，我们不知道他在哪里，他也没说。他确实有一个……澄清一下，因为没有背景，听起来你对整个普锐斯有某种根本性的问题，而且普锐斯是J.F.的错。我是说，我们不知道。那可能是真的。他没告诉我们。你没有澄清你对普锐斯软件有UI问题，而不是对普锐斯作为一辆车的整个概念有意见。
And so at no point are you ever like, am I saying the right thing? Or do I need to spend longer on this point? And it was the point being, I think I could come to love training. But if it was going to be me loving a training course, I would have to basically do all the material from scratch, which... You're volunteering. Yeah, Bryce is like, oh, you just volunteer? No, I'm not volunteering to do that.
我是普锐斯的车主。很棒的车。软件很烂。充电时会让我的手机过热，所以我们不给它充电。总之，在LinkedIn上，它写着“隐形初创公司”。在他的徽章上，写着“隐形”。我能说这个吗？物理系统。实际上，LinkedIn上写了吗？
I do not necessarily... That's not the direction I want to take my career in. But anyways, I have a much greater appreciation for trainers. I assume you're going to be creating all your content, so hopefully that will help with the training process. But anyways, it's very exhausting. I think 90 minutes, in my opinion, it's the perfect talk length. 30 minutes is insanely too short.
LinkedIn上可能也写了。总之，它写着“隐形物理系统初创公司”。所以我们又得到了两个词……我想这就是我们能得到的全部了。这可能是极限了。我是说，我们不能问，而且他被允许说，LinkedIn上写着“物理系统初创公司”。我被纠正了。
45 minutes is okay. An hour's all right. 90's perfect. And eight hours is just insane. But yeah, it's my first time, so. I think you lose people 100 for 90. JF, do you, have you ever done training? I mean, you, I assume when you were at Woven, that you were, you probably were responsible
我们可以随时问，而且他总是被允许说，此时此刻，我不能说更多。可能他会说，其实，我可以告诉你我们到底在做什么。总之，介绍一下你自己，从苹果到丰田，再到谁知道呢。好吧，你知道J.F.过去在哪里工作。NVIDIA。我第一次见到你时其实不知道这一点。我想我当时只是爱上了数组语言。
for some training, like, figuring out, like, training and education. That was probably part of your... We jumped the gun twice. J.F. has never actually formally been interviewed. The last time you were on... Oh, not an interview. Yeah, yeah, not interviewed. The last time you were on was one of the highlights.
你给我讲了一个小故事，说你在NVIDIA创建了一个，我不知道是不是数组DSL。我当时觉得那太疯狂了。我说，为什么那没有流行起来？数组语言、GPU，它们是完美的匹配。听起来你当时正在挖掘金矿，只是你挖得不够深，因为我想你真的，你知道，总之。我们把麦克风交给J.F.。
Highlights of the podcast, we reference it often, folks. We're going to see Sean Parent at C++ Under the Sea in T-minus three weeks, two weeks. And JF was there. Part 1, I think, of that three-part cut, where the part 2 and part 3 were just with Sean was, what's the word? A plethora, a smorgasborg. There's no word to describe what happened. J.F. was there popping in and out and in and out. And I think we had Phil Nash, we had you, we had almost representation from every single C-plus
我觉得我们刚才问了你17个问题，所以请随意回答你想回答的任何问题。给你。嗨，我叫J.F.。你想做什么？是的，我是说，你的AI初创公司是做什么的？这不是一家AI初创公司。我知道。我希望你会不小心回答这个问题，因为很有可能它就是一家AI初创公司。
podcast at the time. Anyways, folks may or may not remember you. You've got to introduce yourself, J.F. I mean, you move to Woven, aka Toyota. We talked about the Prius earlier. He said it wasn't his fault. He actually didn't say that.
但显然你没有上钩。不，我们使用GPU。是的，GPU很好。它们嗡嗡作响。就像，是的，是的，它们做了很多事情。大部分只是嗡嗡作响。是的，是的。是的，你想知道什么？
I'm just being nice. It might have been his fault, folks. But before that, he was at Apple. Now, we don't know where he's at, and he's not telling. He actually does, he does have a... Clarify because it sounds, without context, it sounds like you have some, it sounds like you have some issue fundamentally with the
所以，你想了解动态二进制翻译吗？是的。好吧，不，他问你关于培训的问题。然后我们……所以我雇了Robert Seacord来做很多培训。然后我们。在Woven？是的，心态是什么？作为一个人，当你在组织企业内部培训时，你是什么？
entire Prius and that the Prius is J.F.'s fault. I mean, we don't know. That might be the case. He hasn't told us. You didn't clarify that it was that you have UI issues with the Prius software, not with the whole idea of the Prius's
试图尝试。好吧，我不再是公司代表了，所以我不能正式谈论公司。但是的，我是说，每家拥有各种类型开发人员的大公司都会进行培训，所以培训你的开发人员是有意义的，特别是当你开发安全系统时。所以，一个有趣的方面，这是国际标准的一部分，比如当你进行安全软件开发时，你必须在开发东西时拥有安全心态。这是ISO 26262的一部分，但也是其他标准的一部分。对吧？所以拥有安全心态的一部分实际上是进行针对安全的培训，
a car. I'm an owner of a Prius. Great car. Bad software. It overheats my phone when charging, so we don't charge it. Anyways, on LinkedIn, it says stealth startup. On his badge, it says stealth. Am I allowed to say this? Physical systems. Actually, does it say on LinkedIn?
以及它是什么以及如何应用它。我真的没有培训，但是，是的。我想我们没有安全。你是世界的一部分，做ISO 26262培训。是的，我相信那部分舒适。是的。但是的，你想谈谈二进制翻译吗？你想做什么？
It might say that on LinkedIn as well. Anyways, it says stealth, physical system startup. So we're getting two more words in... I think that's the extent of what we're going to get here. It's probably the extent. I mean, we can't ask, and he's allowed to say, it says physical system startup on LinkedIn. I am corrected.
是的？等等，其实，一个问题出现在我脑海里。TLB Hit。七集。怎么了伙计？是的，所以TLB Hit是我和我的朋友Chris在疫情期间开始的一个每周播客。不，不，它启发了你的播客和Matt Godbolt的播客。你应该回到互联网上看看，互联网是永恒的，我的朋友，没有什么会消失。它是每周一次，就像他们每年在同一周发布一个播客。
And we can always ask, and he is always allowed to say, at this moment in time, I can't say more. And potentially, he'll say, actually, I can tell you exactly what we're doing. Anyways, introduce yourself from Apple to Toyota to who knows. Well, you know where JF used to work back in the dance. Invidia. And I actually didn't know this when we first met. I think I was just falling in love with array languages.
你们在弱内存系统的并发和并行性方面每周工作。播客中会有最终的一致性。但是的，所以Chris和我有一个每周播客叫TLBHit，TLBH.it，tlbh.it。这是一个很棒的播客。我们有很多集。
And you told me a little story where you had created, like, I don't know if it was an array DSL at Nvidia. And I just thought that was crazy. And I was like, why didn't that take over? Like array languages, GPUs, they're a perfect fit. And it sounds like you were tapping on like the goldmine and you just didn't tap hard enough because I think you really, you know, anyways. We're handing the mic to JF.
甚至还有一些未发布的剧集。怎么了？还没发布。是的，我们还没发布。他和他的联合主持人都有孩子。你的联合主持人没有孩子吗？不是一起。我只是想澄清一下。
I feel like we just asked you 17 questions, so feel free to answer as many as you would like. Here you go. Hi, my name's JF. What do you want to do? Yeah, I mean, so what's your AI startup on? It's not an AI startup. I know. I was hoping that you would be like answer the question accidentally because odds are it is an AI startup.
很棒的人，但我们倾向于不……是的，他有双胞胎，然后知道那个孩子。是的，是的。但我们遇到的问题之一是他住在加利福尼亚，我住在日本。所以这使得……在这种情况下很难有孩子。你们俩都住在加利福尼亚时，你们没有发布剧集。好吧，所以当你谈论弱内存系统时，你需要在发布之前获取。
But clearly you didn't fall for the bait. No, we use GPUs. Yeah, GPUs are good. They go burr. It's like, yeah, yeah, they do a lot of stuff. Mostly just going bird. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, what do you want to know?
而且……我记得我忘了它有多痛苦。我知道，我知道。所以是的，但这是一个很棒的播客，录制时真的很开心。我喜欢上播客，很棒的剧集。记得，哦，好吧，它是……我们从零开始计数，但在网站上，你应该去看看。我是说，我查看过了，它会出现在节目说明中，它会出现在节目说明中。等等，我是说，我们最终必须对齐时区，我们会采访J.F.，但我发现我正在深入研究Jax和Jax的后端XLA，现在是OpenXLA，我寻找了一些关于它的演讲。我在网上找到了两个，都是同一个人，一个叫Chris的人，他的姓是什么？Leary？一个叫Chris Leary的人。当时我不知道这是谁。然后，
So, do you want to know about dynamic binary translation? Yeah. Well, no, he asked you about, the first question that was asked was about the training. And then we, uh, so I hired Robert Seacord to do a lot of the trainings. And then we. At Woven? Yeah, what was the mindset? Like, as somebody, as somebody was putting together in corporate internal training, what was like, what were you?
一周后，我心想，等一下，因为我想我看了第二个演讲。第一个演讲很棒。两个演讲都很棒。我心想，等等，这是J.F.的联合主持人。J.F.的联合主持人基本上是，我不知道他是XLA的唯一作者还是合著者，这是实时的，你知道吗？首映的后端。XLS也是？总之，我心想，我们也得让他上播客。我们会请J.F.还是Chris Leary？我不知道，因为他现在在Open AI，所以我们知道这家伙可能是一个亿万富翁。他还在研究XLA吗？你又在哪里工作？提醒我一下？
trying to try. Well, I'm not a company representative anymore, so I can't officially talk about the company. But yeah, I mean, every big company that has a variety of type of developers does training, so it makes sense to train your developers, especially when you develop safety systems. So, like, one interesting aspect, and this is like part of international standards, like when you do safety software development, is you have to have a safety mindset when you develop stuff. That's part of, like, ISO2662, but it's part of other standards as well. Right? So part of having a safety mindset is actually having training towards safety,
NVIDIA？哦，对了。好的，酷。对了。你们刚刚给了Open AI 1000亿美元，对吧？是的，我想我们拥有Open AI。10%左右。我还没查过任何……我在欧洲待了一周。
and what it is and how to apply it. I don't really have training, but, yes. I guess we don't have a safety. You're part of the world that does ISO2662 does trainings. Yeah, I'm sure that that part of the comfort is. Yeah. But yeah, do you want to talk about binary translation? What do you want to do?
我只听说Kimmel被取消了。而且……它没被取消。它没被取消？它没被取消？是的，它没被取消。好吧，那太棒了。我以为……
Yeah? Wait, actually, a question popped into my head. TLB hit. Seven episodes. what's going on buddy yeah so tlb hit is a weekly podcast that my friend chris and i started uh during the pandemic no no it inspired your podcast and and mad godbolt's podcast you should go back you should go back in the internet and look internet is forever my friend nothing vanishes it's weekly in that like they released one podcast in the same week every year
其实，我们要避开这个话题。但我们支持民主。在加拿大，除了我们在挪威，但挪威也支持民主。总之，Chris，XLA的作者或创始人，我发现这非常令人兴奋。
you you guys work on concurrency and parallelism weekly in the same of like weak memory systems. There's going to be eventual, yeah, there's going to be eventual consistency in the podcast. But yeah, so Chris and I have this weekly podcast called TLBHt, TLBH.it, tlbh.it. And it's a wonderful podcast. We have a plethora of episodes.
我有一个有趣的事实告诉你，Chris和我过去在NVIDIA一起工作。什么？是的，Chris在NVIDIA和我一起。所以我们启发了我们的播客，他坐在隔间对面，就在我前面的隔间是Chris。
There's even some unreleased episodes. What's going on? Which haven't. Yeah, we haven't released them. He does have, both him and his co-host have kids. Doesn't your co-host have kids? Not together. I just want to clarify.
所以我周一上班，我出现在工作岗位上，人们向我介绍每个人，然后大约11点左右，他们说，这是Chris的办公室，他还没来。所以我第二天左右见到了Chris，这很不错。是的，所以你在NVIDIA做了什么？等等，等等，是的，你做了什么，为什么离开？我是说……你知道，NVIDIA似乎是一个很棒的工作场所，因为我去过那里，发生了什么？好吧，所以……你知道，NVIDIA除了GPU还制造其他东西，对吧？我不知道，老实说。是的，我做了象牙塔研究。是的，所以我参与了第一个CPU，然后
Wonderful guy, but we tend not to... Yeah, he has twins and then know the kid. Yeah, yeah. But one of the issues we have is he lives in California and I live in Japan. And so it makes it difficult to... It makes it difficult to have kids in that circumstance. You were not releasing episodes when you both live in California. Well, so you need to acquire before you release when we were talking about weak memory systems.
Nvidia设计了叫Project Denver的东西，它在维基百科上，你可以查一下，所以它有一个动态二进制翻译器，将Arm到Arm 64翻译成内部VLIW架构，这非常令人兴奋。
and uh i remember i forgot how painful it is i know i know so yeah but it's a great podcast uh really good times when we record it i love being on podcast amazing episodes remember oh well it's uh we count from zero but it's on the website you should go and check it out i mean i have checked it out it's it's going to be in the show notes it's going to be in show notes wait i mean we will have at some point we actually do have to align time zones and we'll interview jap but i i discovered i was doing a deep dive into Jax and the Jax's back end XLA now OpenXLA and I look for some talks on it. I find two online, both by the same person, a guy named Chris, and what's his last name? Leary? A guy named Chris Leary. At the time I was like, I don't know who this is. And then at
对于这个想法，理论上它可以从其他东西翻译，对吧？所以如果你熟悉历史，我不熟悉。所以你知道Transmeta吗？Transmeta？是的，Transmeta是……它就像一家与Meta竞争的公司。
some point, like a week later, I was like, wait a second, because I think I got to watching the second talk. The first talk was amazing. Both talks were amazing. And I was like, wait, this is JF's co-host. J-F's co-host is basically, I don't know if he was the solo author or the co-author of XLA, which is the live, you know this? The back end to like the premiere. XLS also? Anyway, I was like, we got to have him on the pod too. Will we have J-F or will we have Chris Leary? And I had no idea, because he's at Open AI now, so we know this guy's probably a billionaire. Is he still wondering an X-LIN? Where did you work again? Remind me?
那是90年代的热门初创公司。那是1900年，1990年。而且，Linus过去在那里工作，Linus Torvalds。是的。所以它是一家制造x86芯片的公司，当时与英特尔、AMD和VIA竞争。他们是第一批将真正低功耗芯片推向市场的公司。这真的很酷。他们运送了他们设计的两个CPU，
In video? Oh, right. Okay, cool. Right. You guys just gave $100 billion to Open AI, right? Yeah, I think we owned for an open AI. 10% or something. I haven't checked any... I've been here in Europe for a week.
然后第三个因为某些原因没能成功，但一些知识产权最终流向了其他地方，包括我们正在做的那种东西。这是英特尔起诉他们的原因。你是NVIDIA的代表，你可以告诉我为什么英特尔起诉NVIDIA。我不方便说这个。
All I heard was Kimmel was canceled. And... It's uncanceled. It's uncanceled? It's unc canceled? Yeah, it's unconsled. Well, that's fantastic. I thought...
但在我为NVIDIA工作时有一场诉讼，有一个大约10亿美元的和解协议，这是公开的，你可以去阅读和解协议，里面有一些有趣的条款。英特尔当时为和解支付了NVIDIA大约10亿美元。
Actually, we're going to just veer away from this topic. But we support democracy. here in Canada except we're in Norway but Norway also supports democracy anyways Chris the author or like the founder of XLA I found that very exciting
那大约是他们做MCP的时候。所以，净额我们只给了他们40亿美元。不，所以他们有芯片组。他们是游戏等方面最好的芯片组。这真的很好，你可以把你的GPU插进去。然后围绕它有一场诉讼。你可以去网上查一下。
I have a fun fact for you Chris and I used to work together at NVIDIA what? Yeah Chris was in Vita with me so we inspired to our podcast and he sat right across the cubicle the cubicle right in front of me was Chris
那是他们做的好芯片组。好的。是的。很好的历史。好吧，我离开去谷歌了。等等，你必须去谷歌，然后你去了苹果。是的，然后我去了苹果。是的，我明白了，所以你在向上移动，因为当时NVIDIA没人知道他们是谁。好吧，我知道他们是谁。是的，
and so I start on Monday and I show up at work and people like introduce me to everyone and then it's like 11 or something and they're like so this is chris's office he's not in yet and so i met chris like the next day or something it was pretty good yeah so what did you do it in video wait wait wait yeah what did you do and why did you leave i mean uh you know seems like a pretty great place to work since i've been there what happened well so uh you know invidia builds things other than GPUs right i don't know honestly yeah i did an ivory tower research yeah so i worked on the first CPU then
没人知道他们是谁。我被告知，我被参加这次会议的某个人告知，我应该在2017年不应该去NVIDIA工作，因为他们没有竞争力的薪水，而且它不会像去谷歌、亚马逊、微软或其他地方那样好。但我相信，各位，我相信我认为它是最酷的公司，唯一制造真正并行硬件的公司。好的，我们刚才说到哪了？很酷的故事。
Nvidia designed called Project Denver it's on the Wikipedia as you can look it up and so it has a dynamic binary translator that translates from Arm to Arm 64 to internal VLIW architecture it's very exciting
我不知道从那里该去哪里。你打算告诉我们关于你的初创公司的任何事情吗？是的，这是一家物理系统初创公司，所以我们制造物理东西，你必须编程这些东西并拥有一个平台来编程它们。这非常令人兴奋。他们制造物理东西。
for the idea was that it could translate in theory from other things right so if if you're familiar with history I'm not I'm not so do you know Transmetta Transmeta? Yeah Transmeta was the It was like a company competing with meta.
是的。制造物理东西。是的，这很好。你被允许说关于技术栈的任何事情吗？我是说，我们在谈论Rust，我们在谈论C++，我们在谈论Carbon。你被允许说类似的话吗？这看起来不像专有的，你知道。
It was the hot startup in the 90s. That's in 1900s, 1990. And it was, Linus used to work there, Linus Torval's. Yeah. And so it was a company that made an X-D-6 chip that competed with Intel and AMD and VIA at the time. And they were first to market with really low-powered chips. It was really cool stuff. they shipped two CPUs that they designed
我是说，你必须为工作使用正确的工具。所以Python对于一些AI东西来说相当不错。有大量的C++，Rust。有很棒的TypeScript用于网络相关的东西。你只是在列出所有东西或你使用的一切吗？我们不使用APL。但如果你明天来听我的演讲，我有一个APL笑话，你会喜欢的，你会喜欢的。是的，这是一个很好的演讲，显然我在演讲中，但是
and then the third one kind of didn't really make it because reasons but some of the IP ended up in other places including the type of stuff that we were doing it was the reason that Intel sued them you're the Nvidia representative you can tell me why Intel sued Nvidia I would not be my place to say this
不，我给你看了幻灯片，你在演讲中。是的，正如我告诉他们的，我会在飞机上，所以我不能参加他的演讲。不，你在演讲中，它完成了。是的，你在JF的演讲之前离开非常粗鲁。我知道，我知道，我知道我永远不会错过，因为JF著名地——我想这可能是错的，如果是的话我会剪掉它——你只做一次演讲，对吧？是的，是的。所以我是说，我上次现场看你的演讲是在C++ Under the Sea。我想你从那以后做过演讲，在中间，因为那是几年前的事了。不，2020年。
but there was a lawsuit at the time I worked at Nvidia and there was a settlement for around a billion dollars which is public you can go and read the settlement and it has interesting clauses in it. And Intel at the time paid Nvidia around a billion dollars for the settlement.
但在我于英伟达工作期间发生了一起诉讼，最终以约十亿美元达成和解，这是公开信息，你可以去查阅和解协议，里面有一些有趣的条款。当时英特尔为了和解向英伟达支付了约十亿美元。
It was around the time they did MCP. So, so net we only gave them $4 billion. No, so they had chipsets. They were like the best chipsets for gaming and stuff. It was really good, and you could plug your GPU into it and stuff. And then there was a lawsuit around it. You could just go look it up online.
那大约是在他们做MCP的时候。所以，总共我们只给了他们40亿美元。不，他们当时有芯片组。那些芯片组在游戏等方面表现极佳，非常好用，你可以把GPU插在上面。后来围绕这个发生了一场诉讼。你可以在网上查到。
It was a good chip set thing that they did. Okay. Yeah. Good history. Well, I left to go to Google. wait you have to go to google and then you went to apple yeah and then i went to apple yeah i see so you were moving up in the because at the time invidia nobody knew who they were well i knew who they were yeah
他们做的那个芯片组确实不错。好的。是的。很好的历史。嗯，我离开去了谷歌。等等，你得先去谷歌，然后去了苹果，是的，然后我去了苹果，是的，我明白了，所以你在不断晋升，因为当时没人知道英伟达是谁，好吧，我知道他们是谁，是的。
nobody knew who they were i was i was told i was told by somebody who's at this conference that i should like in 2017 that i should not go work at invidia because they did not have competitive pay and and uh that it was not going to be as good as going to google or amazon or Microsoft or somewhere. But I believe, folks, I believed I thought it was the coolest company, the only company that made True Parallel Hardware. Okay, where were we? Cool story.
没人知道他们是谁。我记得在2017年，有人在这次会议上告诉我，我不应该去英伟达工作，因为他们的薪酬没有竞争力，而且不如去谷歌、亚马逊、微软或其他地方好。但我相信，伙计们，我相信我认为它是最酷的公司，是唯一一家制造真正并行硬件的公司。好了，我们刚才说到哪了？很酷的故事。
I don't know where to go from there. Are you about to tell us anything about your startup? Yeah, it's a physical system startup, and so we build physical things, and you've got to program those things and have a platform to be able to program them. It's very exciting. They build physical things.
我不知道接下来该说什么了。你打算告诉我们关于你创业公司的事吗？是的，这是一家物理系统初创公司，我们制造物理实体，你必须对这些东西进行编程，并拥有一个能够对其进行编程的平台。这非常令人兴奋。他们制造物理实体。
Yeah. Build physical things. Yeah, it's nice. Are you allowed to say anything about the tech stack? I mean, we're talking rust. We're talking C++, we're talking carbon. Are you allowed to say anything like that? That doesn't seem like proprietary, you know.
是的。制造物理实体。是的，这很好。你被允许透露任何关于技术栈的信息吗？我的意思是，我们谈论的是Rust，我们谈论的是C++，我们谈论的是Carbon。你被允许说这些吗？这看起来不像是专有的，你知道的。
I mean, you've got to use the right tool for the job. So the Python's pretty decent for some AI stuff. There's a good amount of C++, rust. There's great typescript for web-related stuff. Are you just listening off everything or everything you use? We don't use APL. But if you come to my talk tomorrow, have an APL joke you'll like it you'll like it yeah it's a good talk apparently i'm in the talk but
我的意思是，你必须为工作选择合适的工具。所以Python在某些人工智能方面相当不错。还有大量的C++和Rust。对于网络相关的东西，TypeScript也很棒。你是在列举所有东西还是你使用的所有东西？我们不用APL。但如果你明天来听我的演讲，我有一个关于APL的笑话，你会喜欢的，你会喜欢的，是的，这是一个很好的演讲，显然我在演讲中，但是
no i showed you the slide you're in the talk yeah as i told them i'll be on a plane so i can't be in his talk no you are in the talk it's done yeah very rude that you would leave before jf's talk i know i know i know i would never miss because jrf famously i think actually this could be wrong i'll cut it if it is you only give your talks once right yeah yeah so i mean the last time i saw a talk of yours live was at c plus plus under the sea I imagine you've given a talk since then, in between, because that was like a couple years ago. No, 2020.
不，我给你看了幻灯片，你在演讲里，是的，正如我告诉他们的，我会在飞机上，所以我不能参加他的演讲，不，你在演讲里，已经定好了，是的，你在JF的演讲前离开非常粗鲁，我知道，我知道，我知道，我绝不会错过，因为JF很有名，我想实际上这可能是错的，如果是的话我会剪掉它，你只做一次演讲对吧，是的，是的，所以我的意思是，我上次现场看你的演讲是在C++ Under the Sea，我想在那之后你肯定做过演讲，因为那是几年前的事了。不，是2020年。
So I guess that's a year and a half from 2025 now. Have you given talks in between? Can we link them in the show notes? Or is this year return from a year and a half? I think I gave a C++ now talk, the safety and security one. The CPP on C1 was my most popular, though. It was a good talk, yeah. That was, like, book-ended with, like, it was, there was three safety and security talks.
所以我猜距离2025年还有一年半的时间。这期间你做过演讲吗？我们能在节目简介里放上链接吗？还是说今年是你时隔一年半的回归？我想我做过一次C++ Now演讲，关于安全和保障的那场。不过CPPCon上的那场是我最受欢迎的。那确实是一场不错的演讲。那次演讲的前后，大概有三场关于安全和保障的演讲。
Sean gave one, you gave one. I can't remember the third one. I apologize to that person, but I definitely recall... I made a panel. I made a panel also. Was that recorded? Yeah, I think so. I might, was that C++ now?
肖恩做了一场，你也做了一场。我不记得第三场是谁了。向那位演讲者道歉，但我确实记得……我参加了一个小组讨论。我也参加了一个小组讨论。那场录音了吗？是的，我想录了。我可能……那是C++ Now吗？
Yeah, I think so. I might have watched that as well. But I definitely remember enjoying both yours and Sean's. Sean, I mean, Sean's fantastic. He's always got great takes. Anyway, so this is your first talk since... Was it C++ now this year? Honestly.
是的，我想是的。我可能也看过那场。但我确实记得很喜欢你和肖恩的演讲。肖恩，我是说，肖恩太棒了。他总是有很棒的见解。总之，这是你自……那是今年的C++ Now吗？说实话。
Two, three years ago. Because I was going to say that, it feels like ages ago when I watched that talk. Anyways, tell us a little bit about your talk. I mean, Victoria, you're speaking tomorrow as well, right? He spoke today. So, wait, we'll go to Vitorio first. Give us a recap. How did your talk go?
两三年前了。因为我正想说，看那场演讲感觉像是很久以前的事了。总之，给我们介绍一下你的演讲吧。我是说，维托里奥，你明天也要演讲，对吧？他今天讲过了。等等，我们先找维托里奥。给我们总结一下。你的演讲怎么样？
And then we'll get a preview of J.F's talk tomorrow. I know... Wait, hold back to... Wait. No, I... Jason's talk is called implicit conversions considered harmful. Your talk is called hoping, noping, what about noping or something like that? Much ado about noping.
然后我们再预告一下J.F.明天的演讲。我知道……等等，回到……等等。不，我……杰森的演讲叫《隐式转换被视为有害》。你的演讲叫《希望，不希望，关于不希望什么的？》叫《无事生非》。
So it's a talk about nothing. It's really good. I've been working on it for eight years. Eight years. All right. That's a bit much. But I do recall, I got the nop or the noping correct. We got 50 minutes before this quiz.
所以这是一个关于“无（nop）”的演讲。真的很棒。我已经为此准备了八年了。八年。好吧。那有点夸张了。但我确实记得，我把nop或者noping搞对了。在这次测验前我们还有50分钟。
Vittorio's talk, I don't think I recall. I definitely didn't see it today. day but tell us how did your talk go what was it about so not only you didn't come to my talk wait what time is it at what time is it at you don't even know if you came too much all no no no i definitely know i wasn't in it i was only in two and a half talks today i'm pretty offended i think i want bryce to ask me questions from now and is that okay what time is it at though what time was it was at 10 30 that's why i wasn't i was running during that he said he would definitely be at my talk which is at the same time so
维托里奥的演讲，我不记得了。我今天肯定没看。但告诉我们你的演讲怎么样，讲了什么？所以不仅你没来听我的演讲，等等，那是几点？那是几点？你甚至不知道你是不是去得太多了……不不不，我肯定知道我没去。我今天只听了两场半演讲。我挺受冒犯的，我想从现在开始让布莱斯问我问题，这样可以吗？不过那是几点？那是10点30分，所以我没去，我当时在跑步。他说他一定会去听我的演讲，而那场演讲在同一时间，所以……
Yeah, I mean I used to talk we were friends I used to thought we had, you know, something but... There's no way to back on to this one. I know, I know. I mean, the audience heard everything so they can make their own mind, right?
是啊，我是说我们以前经常聊天，我们是朋友，我以为我们之间，你知道，有什么……这事没法挽回了。我知道，我知道。我是说，观众都听到了，所以他们可以自己判断，对吧？
They'll understand this biases. Go to the GitHub discussion and you be the judge. You meet the comic. Anyway, my talk went great. I gave this talk, also CVPCon as a keynote, which was my first ever keynote. So...
他们会理解这些偏见的。去GitHub讨论区，你来评判。你来见见那个漫画。总之，我的演讲很棒。我做了这场演讲，也是CPPCon的主题演讲，这是我第一次做主题演讲。所以……
Is it online right now? It is online right now. It was shared like immediately afterwards, and please go see it. Let me know if you enjoyed it. It's about data-oriented design. And... Wait, what design?
现在网上有吗？现在网上有了。演讲结束后立刻就分享了，请一定要去看。如果喜欢的话告诉我。是关于面向数据设计的。而且……等等，什么设计？
Data-oriented design. That sounds like the Mike Acton talk of like the CPP on 2014 or something. Exactly. That's the right year. And I actually started with it in my keynote because I was there in person and it was like the personal start on my journey to DOD. I think to this day that is like one of the top five viewed... Is it V?
面向数据设计。听起来像是迈克·阿克顿在2014年CPPCon上的那场演讲。没错。就是那一年。我实际上在主题演讲中提到了它，因为我当时就在现场，那是我踏上DOD（面向数据设计）之旅的起点。我认为直到今天，那仍然是观看次数排名前五的……是V吗？
It's number one. J.F's correcting me. I mean, I'm not wrong in it was the number one. of the top five, but J.F. is qualifying. It is the number one view talk on all of CBPCON videos released in history. Yeah, I feel like Mike's keynote was eye-opening for other people, me included. I do feel like it's very dogmatic onto some stuff, especially regarding C++ feature usage and templates and abstraction. So I try to have a little bit of a more balanced outlook and kind of like balance out DOD with OOP, which are supposed to be more total enemies, but I'm not.
是第一名。J.F.在纠正我。我是说，我说它是前五名并没有错，但J.F.在限定范围。它是CPPCon历史上所有发布视频中观看次数第一的演讲。是的，我觉得迈克的主题演讲对其他人，包括我，都是一种启发。我确实觉得它在某些方面非常教条，特别是在C++特性使用、模板和抽象方面。所以我尝试用一种更平衡的视角，试图平衡DOD和OOP，它们本应是死对头，但我并不这么认为。
I think they can coexist, and also I believe that there is quite a lot of room for civil plus features and obstructions to actually make your life easier. One of the things I show in the talk, for example, is taking a normal struct and automatically converting it to an SOA layout using reflection even in Salesforce 17, and it's actually one of the... That example is one of the ones that we actually contributed to the whole reflection effort, and that's one of my favorite things. But I'm doing this in Silas Plus 17.
我认为它们可以共存，而且我相信C++的特性和抽象有很大的空间可以让你的生活更轻松。我在演讲中展示的一件事，例如，使用反射将普通结构体自动转换为SOA布局，即使是在C++17中也可以做到，这实际上是……那个例子是我们为整个反射工作所贡献的例子之一，那是我最喜欢的事情之一。但我是在C++17中做到的。
You can do it, you can do it before 2012-76. I did see, was it on LinkedIn, it was some social media platform where you posted, everyone's excited about C++26 reflection, but don't forget, we can do a lot of this stuff. Yeah, that's it, that's it. So it's like everybody is super excited for reflection, but many of the use cases that are very useful with reflection, you can do today. You have boost BFR, you have this weird, arcane magical tricks that you're going to do with templates to even extract names of fields from Strux in a portable way,
你可以在2012-76之前做到。我确实看到了，是在LinkedIn还是什么社交媒体平台上，你发帖说，大家对C++26的反射很兴奋，但别忘了，我们现在就能做很多这类事情。是的，就是这样。所以就像每个人都对反射超级兴奋，但很多反射非常有用的用例，你今天就能做到。你有Boost PFR，你有这些奇怪、深奥的魔法技巧，你可以用模板以可移植的方式从结构体中提取字段名称，
and then reflect on those in 17. Or maybe it's 24 for the field names and 17 for aggregates. But still, you have a lot of power today that people maybe don't even know you have, which is a bit of sad because you can do automatic serialization, automatic data layout changing. You can do quite a lot of cool stuff nowadays with what you have at your disposal. That's amazing. And the great news is, I don't know, exactly. All right, JFS is gone.
然后在C++17中对它们进行反射。或者可能是C++24用于字段名称，C++17用于聚合体。但即便如此，你今天拥有的能力比人们可能意识到的要多得多，这有点令人遗憾，因为你可以做自动序列化、自动数据布局更改。你现在可以利用手头的工具做很多很酷的事情。太棒了。好消息是，我不知道，没错。好了，J.F.走了。
We won't ever hear about its talk. I mean, I guess he said it was about nothing. He's been working on it for eight years. Seems odd. The great news is that even if NDC Techtown doesn't release the video at the time this is released at some time probably late October, we will have a link to the keynote that was given at CPPCon. And this does sound like a fantastic talk. It's not a repeat or a different edition of Mike Acton's talk.
我们永远听不到关于他演讲的内容了。我是说，我猜他说那是关于“无”的。他为此准备了八年。看起来很奇怪。好消息是，即使NDC Techtown在发布时没有发布视频，大概在10月下旬，我们也会有CPPCon主题演讲的链接。这听起来确实是一场精彩的演讲。它不是迈克·阿克顿演讲的重复或不同版本。
It is an extension. A less angry version of Mike. Was Mike's talk angry? Victoria gave a less angry version of Mike's talk. Mike was angry. I don't remember much about the thing. He was angry. He was angry?
它是它的延伸。一个不那么愤怒的迈克版本。迈克的演讲很愤怒吗？维托里奥做了一个不那么愤怒的迈克演讲版本。迈克很愤怒。我不记得关于那件事的太多细节了。他很愤怒。他很愤怒吗？
I feel like I didn't want to do the same thing at Mysacton. I took a different approach where it's like a walk-through. I show people, hey, let's start with an OOP sort of thing, then we benchmark it. We see why it's low. We talk about memory. Then we actually gradually migrate to something more data-oriented. We benchmark it again.
我觉得我不想做和迈克·阿克顿一样的事情。我采取了不同的方法，就像一个演练。我向人们展示，嘿，让我们从OOP开始，然后我们对其进行基准测试。我们看看为什么它很慢。我们谈论内存。然后我们逐渐迁移到更面向数据的东西。我们再次进行基准测试。
So it's a very kind of like step-by-step approach where you see pedagogically how you can shift your mindset and now that actually affects the final runtime of the project. So I feel like Mike Acton is very angry talk, if you want to call it that way, still has a lot of value, and I recommend people to see it. It's very different thing. So I don't want to, you know, overlap on the same thing. I do just want to say, don't get me wrong.
所以这是一种非常循序渐进的方法，你可以从教学角度看到如何转变思维方式，以及这如何实际影响项目的最终运行时间。所以我认为迈克·阿克顿那场非常愤怒的演讲，如果你想这么称呼它的话，仍然非常有价值，我建议人们去看看。那是完全不同的东西。所以我不想，你知道，在同一件事上重叠。我只是想说，别误会我的意思。
Well, I do think it was an angry talk. It was one of the best talks I've ever seen. That is up there with Sean Parents, C++ Now, keynote from like 2012 or 2013, the one we always talk about that we love, where he shows, where he basically talks about GP programming in the early days. I feel more than angry, the right word is frustrated, and you can be frustrated for very good reasons, and I feel like that's what motivated Mike.
嗯，我确实认为那是一场愤怒的演讲。那是我看过的最好的演讲之一。它和肖恩·帕伦特在2012年或2013年C++ Now上的主题演讲并列，就是我们总是谈论并喜爱的那个，他在那里基本上谈论了早期的泛型编程。我觉得比起愤怒，更准确的词是沮丧，你可以因为非常正当的理由感到沮丧，我觉得这就是激励迈克的原因。
Well, I was going to say, I don't think there's anything wrong with having a little emotion, a little anger, a little frustration. To be honest, I think I'm way too Canadian nice, and there's times on these podcasts where the voice in my head is like, blah-la-la-la-la-la-la-ha-ha-ha. And literally, my wife, Shima, or I guess fiancé. say soon to be wife, she'll be like, she'll be listening to it in the car and then she'll give me feedback. And then she'll be like, why don't you push back harder? And she'll be,
嗯，我正想说，我不认为带有一点情绪、一点愤怒、一点沮丧有什么错。老实说，我觉得我太像加拿大人那样友好了，在这个播客里，有时候我脑子里的声音会说，啦啦啦啦啦啦啦。字面上，我的妻子希玛，或者我猜是未婚妻，快要成为妻子的她，她会在车里听，然后给我反馈。然后她会说，你为什么不反驳得更强硬一点？然后她会……
oh, you know, I completely disagree with the point being made. And she's like, well, why don't you push back? And I was like, well, you know, I don't want to be disagreeable. But the point being is emotion. And it's like, you can still respectfully have like an emotional kind of reaction to someone's opinion and say, listen, you know, I appreciate that's your opinion. But I wholeheartedly think you're completely wrong. And it's actually good for, it's good for ratings, you know. I think in the year of 2025, in the last decade and a half, people are too worried about upsetting listeners and guests and stuff. Like, we've lost the ability to have, like, honest conversations. Anyways, so a goal going forward, or at least she's trying to convince me is,
哦，你知道，我完全不同意刚才提出的观点。她说，好吧，你为什么不反驳？我说，嗯，你知道，我不想显得不合群。但重点是情绪。就像，你仍然可以尊重地对某人的观点做出情绪化的反应，并说，听着，我知道那是你的观点。但我完全认为你完全错了。而且这实际上对收视率有好处，你知道。我认为在2025年，在过去的十五年里，人们太担心惹恼听众和嘉宾之类的事情了。就像，我们已经失去了进行诚实对话的能力。总之，一个前进的目标，或者至少她试图说服我的是，
like, whenever I disagree with whether it's a guest or a host, you just say, listen, I appreciate your point of view, but you're wrong. And you know, and then you go, but respectfully. And anyways, Victoria wants to add to that. Yes, the message, of course, is be angry. That's what we're saying. And also, you said you're Canadian-knives, or you've been very mean to me today. I will not forget that. It is true. I didn't know the name. I knew the name of JF's talk. Well, actually, I didn't know the name of JF's talk,
就像，每当我不同意嘉宾或主持人的观点时，你就说，听着，我欣赏你的观点，但你是错的。然后你知道，然后你说，但要尊重。总之，维托里奥想补充一点。是的，信息当然是，要愤怒。这就是我们所说的。而且，你说你是加拿大人式的友好，或者你今天对我非常刻薄。我不会忘记的。这是真的。我不知道名字。我知道J.F.演讲的名字。好吧，其实我不知道J.F.演讲的名字，
but I did say I would be at it. And I knew the name of Jason's talk. And Jason, he's not around. I think he's gone. We might talk to him tomorrow. And by we, I mean, me, because Bryce is going to be gone. But I did not know. I mean, I do recall reviewing the schedule, but I was trying to fit in a 20K run. And so I had to choose. is a two-talk slot, and the morning slot was the one. And if it makes you feel better, I miss lunch today because I missed... I thought if I showed up before, it doesn't.
但我确实说过我会去听。我知道杰森演讲的名字。而杰森，他不在了。我想他走了。我们明天可能会和他谈谈。我说的“我们”，是指我，因为布莱斯要走了。但我不知道。我是说，我确实记得查看过日程表，但我当时正试图完成一次20公里的跑步。所以我必须做出选择。这是一个双演讲时段，早上的时段是那个。如果这能让你感觉好点，我今天错过了午餐，因为我错过了……我以为如果我提前出现，那没用。
All right. Vittoria says it does not make him feel better. We will rectify this situation by going and watching the CPP keynote, either on the train to Oslo or sometime before then. Wait, wait, wait, was you going to talk, a keynote? So it's already online. That's when he said keynote, I was like, a lot of times now, C++ now, CPPCon. Here, here's a hot take and a disagreement.
好吧。维托里奥说这并不能让他感觉好点。我们将通过去观看CPP主题演讲来纠正这种情况，要么是在去奥斯陆的火车上，要么是在那之前。等等，等等，你要去演讲，主题演讲？所以它已经在网上了。当他说主题演讲时，我就想，现在很多时候，C++ Now，CPPCon。这里，这里有一个激进的观点和分歧。
Stop doing this thing where you wait like four months and then you roll out talks like what I get, you think it's good for the algorithm, but you're upsetting, you're loyal, like, watcher fans. It's not about the algorithm. It's not? It's not about the algorithm. It's about selling in-person tickets.
别再做这种等上四个月然后才放出演讲的事情了，你以为这对算法有好处，但你正在惹恼你忠实的观众粉丝。这不是关于算法。不是吗？这不是关于算法。这是关于销售现场门票。
If they put the video as up immediately, the thinking is, people are less likely to come in person. If you want to see the keynote without a four-month delay, you've got to come in person. that's a broken mindset though because people I mean at least people that have been to a you don't go to the conference for the talks you go to the conference for the conversations the hallway track I mean honestly the most valuable thing about this trip was our conversation that we had in Copenhagen over that dinner and I explained to you the iterator invalidation thing
如果他们立即发布视频，他们的想法是，人们亲自参加的可能性就会降低。如果你想在没有四个月延迟的情况下看到主题演讲，你就必须亲自到场。但那是一种破碎的心态，因为人们，我是说至少去过会议的人，你参加会议不是为了演讲，你是为了对话，为了走廊交流。我是说老实说，这次旅行最有价值的事情就是我们在哥本哈根晚餐时的谈话，我向你解释了迭代器失效的事情，
and you were like that doesn't sound like an iterator invalidation thing since then I've gone and fixed that issue it's as JF says the GPU goes burr and we've got our row wise softmax working in two kernels. It's beautiful folks, and I am more confident about this library that we're launching than ever. We haven't talked about it yet, but the point being, that has nothing to do about, it's the in-person conversations that you have with people. It's not about the talks that you watch. I mean, admittedly, you do learn stuff from the talks you watch, but like the most valuable stuff is these moments right here. All right, we're headed to Victoria because he's the guest. So I'm going to organize a conference with no talks. It's going to be 3K per entry, and you're going
你说那听起来不像迭代器失效的事情，从那以后我去修复了那个问题，正如J.F.所说，GPU运转起来了，我们已经在两个内核中完成了行向Softmax。这很美，伙计们，我对我们即将推出的这个库比以往任何时候都更有信心。我们还没谈过它，但重点是，这与演讲无关，而是你与人们进行的面对面交谈。这与你观看的演讲无关。我是说，诚然，你确实从观看的演讲中学到了东西，但最有价值的东西是这些时刻。好吧，我们要去找维托里奥，因为他是嘉宾。所以我打算组织一个没有演讲的会议。入场费3000，你会
beat here, right? Honestly, that is like, you're joking, that's a pretty decent idea. Like, they have had these kind of co-located, like, what do they call, unconferences where there are no scheduled talks, but they just get together a, yeah, there's a space, and so you'll have this kind of either one or two rooms, and then at some point they'll do, like, hey, does someone have something they want to show or whatever, show and tell? Or maybe someone does have a presentation they want to show. Like, I think that those are a lot hard.
在这里，对吧？老实说，那就像，你在开玩笑，那是个相当不错的主意。就像，他们有这种共址的，他们称之为什么，非会议，没有预定的演讲，但他们只是聚在一起，是的，有一个空间，然后在某个时候他们会做，嘿，有人有什么想展示的吗，或者什么，展示和讲述？或者也许有人确实有一个他们想展示的演示文稿。就像，我认为那些很难
to like fund and to get people to show up to but like it's a joke but I think there's actually a ton of value in that kind of stuff because if you can make it work right it is the best form of like unstructured conversations blah blah brako groups anyways so I think you could be massively on I mean it's not my point these things exist like unconferences are a thing I went to one for I don't remember what but it was some some Google thing so I uh I don't know we've mentioned this in the podcast before, but me and Ramon and I are in the nascent stages of planning a New York-based conference, and we keep having this conversation about maybe we just won't have keynotes because I feel like a Vittorio keynote's going to be good, but I feel like
去资助并让人们出现，但这是一个玩笑，但我认为这类事情实际上非常有价值，因为如果你能让它奏效，它是最好的非结构化对话形式，等等等等。所以我认为你可能非常有道理。我是说，这不是我的观点，这些事情确实存在，非会议是一回事，我参加过一次，我不记得是为了什么，但那是谷歌的某个东西，所以我……我不知道，我们在播客中提到过这一点，但我、拉蒙和我在规划一个纽约会议的萌芽阶段，我们一直在进行关于也许我们只是不设主题演讲的对话，因为我觉得维托里奥的主题演讲会很好，但我感觉
on average, I am disappointed with keynotes at a lot of conferences. No, legitimately, I am disappointed with a lot of keynotes because I think that oftentimes they give people keynotes and they got an open check about what they're going to present. And there's no review or feedback process on the keynote. And so sometimes you get keynotes where they're just not so good. I will say there was that, was it a blog post or conference trip report? At some point I posted somewhere, for the love of God. And I'll call out the conference.
平均而言，我对很多会议的主题演讲感到失望。不，合情合理，我对很多主题演讲感到失望，因为我认为他们往往给人们主题演讲，而他们对要展示的内容有一张空白支票。而且主题演讲没有审查或反馈过程。所以有时你会得到一些主题演讲，它们就是不太好。我会说有那个，是博客文章还是会议旅行报告？在某个时候我发在某处，看在上帝的份上。我会点名那个会议。
It was CPPCon. Please use a monospace font for your code examples. just because it's in a slide deck doesn't mean and everybody I mean calling out a very specific person No no I would
那是CPPCon。请为你的代码示例使用等宽字体。仅仅因为它在幻灯片里并不意味着……而且每个人，我是说点名一个非常具体的人，不不，我会……
Three of the five keynotes did this And one of them Everybody's gonna think you're calling out of I mean that's fine I honestly I honestly don't care We just finished saying That it's okay To have disagreements with people
五个主题演讲中有三个做了这个，而且其中一个……每个人都会认为你在点名……我是说那没关系，我老实说，我老实说不在乎。我们刚刚说完，与人有分歧是可以的。
And honestly using a monosee spot It's not a lot of work It's not a lot of work folks You can do it I can do it we can all do it And I don't Unless if your talk is about Like what's the guys
而且老实说，使用等宽字体，这不需要很多工作。这不需要很多工作，伙计们。你可以做到，我可以做到，我们所有人都能做到。而且我除非你的演讲是关于……像那个家伙是谁
named Brett Victor and he has this whole thing is that like we're stuck in this like page of text everything is blah blah blah it should be a newspaper some things should be bigger like the function names that unless if you have a talk about the way that we're formatting and styling code I want to see a monospace font it's easier to pattern recognize like it's just it's just the the coding standard there's no IDE or like editor or any online tool that offers you a non monospace font and when I see it I'm just like what I would doing here? And it is just laziness. I'm going to be honest, it's just laziness. You're copy and you posting and you're not choosing the font. I guarantee you, Victoria's talk, it had a monospace font.
叫布雷特·维克多，他有整套理论，就像我们被困在这一页文字里，一切都是blah blah blah，它应该是一份报纸，有些东西应该更大，比如函数名，除非你的演讲是关于我们格式化和样式化代码的方式，否则我想看到等宽字体，它更容易进行模式识别，就像它只是……它只是编码标准，没有任何IDE或编辑器或任何在线工具为你提供非等宽字体，当我看到它时，我只是想，我在这里做什么？这只是懒惰。老实说，这只是懒惰。你在复制粘贴，你没有选择字体。我保证，维托里奥的演讲，它有等宽字体。
I can say that confidently because, well, actually, I'm 99% confident. Victoria can let us know. I just want to add that, like, you mentioned there's no editor, but my university professor's my favorite editor, Microsoft Word, comes with a non-monospace font, and all the code was written there. But he didn't use one, but yeah, yeah. I agree. would you like in general, I feel like is the bare minimum you can do to make your slight more readable and making code monospace. And I'm still surprised that sometimes even very technically good talks, you know, completely do not care about the aspect of visual presentation and making things more readable, which is a bit of a shame. Yeah. I mean, I do think,
我可以自信地说，好吧，其实我有99%的把握。维托里奥可以告诉我们。我只是想补充一点，就像，你提到没有编辑器，但我大学教授最喜欢的编辑器，Microsoft Word，自带非等宽字体，所有的代码都是在那里写的。但他没用那个，但是的，是的。我同意。你觉得总的来说，我觉得让你的幻灯片更易读和让代码等宽是你至少能做的。而且我仍然很惊讶，有时即使是技术上非常好的演讲，你知道，完全不关心视觉呈现和让事情更易读的方面，这有点遗憾。是的。我是说，我确实认为，
and then this is, we're in hot take territory, folks. I do really think it is just like a lack of effort. It's not that it's not a good talk. It's just literally like it's extra effort to go and change the font and they just copy pasta and they're done with it. Right now I'm on Linux folks and I make my talks in Microsoft 365 PowerPoint, the web version, and I lose my indentation. I get the I get the syntax isolating. I've learned a trick from Ashman here. He's not saying much, but he's offering a lot and he taught me the trick on how to, and actually I'll tell you the trick. You got a copy to Google slides first and then to Microsoft online. I haven't tested it yet, but I trust that it works.
然后这是，我们处于激进观点领域，伙计们。我真的认为这只是缺乏努力。并不是说这不是一场好的演讲。这只是字面上，去改变字体需要额外的努力，他们只是复制粘贴，然后就完成了。现在我在Linux上，伙计们，我在Microsoft 365 PowerPoint网页版上制作我的演讲，我丢失了缩进。我得到了语法高亮。我从这里的阿什曼那里学到了一招。他没说什么，但他提供了很多，他教了我如何……其实我会告诉你这一招。你得先复制到Google Slides，然后再到Microsoft Online。我还没测试过，但我相信它有效。
But for the talk that I gave at the meetup at Roku and the meetup in Copenhagen, I went in painstakingly. Every code example, I went and I typed space by space for every single indentation. And I tried to choose code examples that had the minimum level of nestedness, because if you get three levels, that's 12 spaces I have to type. But that's how much I care. Like, it is my fault for not suffering through Windows, because Windows has the copy pasta working correctly.
但对于我在Roku的聚会和哥本哈根的聚会上做的演讲，我费尽心思。每一个代码示例，我都进去，为每一个缩进逐个输入空格。而且我尽量选择嵌套程度最低的代码示例，因为如果你有三层，那就是我必须输入的12个空格。但这就是我关心的程度。就像，这是我的错，因为我没有忍受Windows，因为Windows的复制粘贴工作正常。
But the point being, folks, is you should care. You should care. Changing the font is a single click. We got multiple people with comments here. I'm going to make a certain specific coworker of ours. Listen to this. Because there's a certain slide deck which has code, which not only is in a non-monospace font, it's also got no indentation. It's all on the left line.
但重点是，伙计们，你应该关心。你应该关心。改变字体只需点击一下。我们这里有多个人发表评论。我要让我们的某个特定同事听听这个。因为有某个幻灯片包含代码，不仅是非等宽字体，而且还没有缩进。它全部左对齐。
We're handing it to Vittoria, but I'm going to beep this out. Who is it? I'll beep it out. I'll beep it out. I'll beep it out. You're not getting it from me. Yeah, that's unsurprising. It's beeped out, though. Don't worry. Because we're talking about venting our frustrations, PowerPoint, it lacks one of the most basic features that every program has, which is resizing text proportionally. Like, if you drag from
我们要把它交给维托里奥，但我会把这个消音。是谁？我会消音的。我会消音的。我会消音的。你不会从我这里得到它。是的，这并不令人惊讶。不过它被消音了。别担心。因为我们在谈论发泄我们的挫折感，PowerPoint，它缺乏每个程序都拥有的最基本的功能之一，那就是按比例调整文本大小。就像，如果你从
the corner of the text box, it's just going to resize the boundaries, and it's going to reflow the text. And I like morphing. I like when I have Slizer move around and Code Movers around. So at the beginning, I used to do this. I used to convert everything. single text box into an image so that I can resize it proportionally. And whenever I had to make a change in the keynote, I had to do it from scratch, change the code, and then reconvert to an image and morph it again. And then realized, I'm a programmer. I can fix things.
文本框的角落拖动，它只会调整边界，并且会重新排版文本。我喜欢变形。我喜欢当我有幻灯片移动和代码移动时。所以起初，我过去常这样做。我过去常把每一个文本框转换成图像，这样我就可以按比例调整它的大小。每当我在主题演讲中必须做出更改时，我必须从头开始，更改代码，然后重新转换成图像并再次变形。然后意识到，我是一个程序员。我可以修复事情。
So I made an ad-DIN for PowerPoint that allows you to actually proportionally resize text. And, you know, do you have no excuse? If you want to make it look good, you can even go beyond and just fix PowerPoint. Which Microsoft should do, honestly. It's been 20 years, 40 years, and still you cannot resize things properly. Unfortunately, that makes me frustrated. I'll pay you like 20 euros for the plug-in. I was going to say, is it public?
所以我为PowerPoint制作了一个插件，允许你实际按比例调整文本大小。而且，你知道，你没有借口？如果你想让它看起来不错，你甚至可以更进一步，直接修复PowerPoint。老实说，微软应该这样做。已经20年，40年了，你仍然不能正确地调整大小。不幸的是，这让我感到沮丧。我会付给你20欧元买这个插件。我正想说，它是公开的吗？
I mean, that is an amazing point. I mean, I think that the text, if you resize it, yeah, yeah, the quiz is starting. So we are ending this conversation. It's good timing because it's been 45 minutes. But I'm pretty sure if you resize it, it just goes outside the bounds of the box. And so you actually only have to, but it is a good point.
我是说，那是一个了不起的观点。我是说，我认为文本，如果你调整它的大小，是的，是的，测验开始了。所以我们要结束这次对话。时机很好，因为已经45分钟了。但我很确定如果你调整它的大小，它只是超出了框的边界。所以你实际上只需要，但这确实是一个好观点。
It should fix that. We didn't even talk about Vitorio's background and, like, game design. But that's such a, now that you've said that, like, I definitely want that. And I haven't realized until now that that's something that I needed. We have to have Vitorio clearly on the pod because Bryce and I care deeply about PowerPoint. We spend an inordinate amount of time. There's a couple episodes that I've titled like C++X or Y. It's a 40-minute podcast.
它应该修复那个。我们甚至没有谈论维托里奥的背景和，比如，游戏设计。但那是一个如此，既然你这么说了，就像，我绝对想要那个。直到现在我才意识到那是我需要的东西。我们必须让维托里奥明确地出现在播客上，因为布莱斯和我非常关心PowerPoint。我们花费了大量的时间。有几集我标题为像C++ X或Y。这是一个40分钟的播客。
30 minutes are talking about PowerPoint and really should have PowerPoint in the title. Anyways, maybe we'll chat with you afterwards, Vitori. Thank you for coming on. We'll get you on a formal interview. Thanks for coming on. I would love that. Thank you so much. If people want to hire you to do training, where do they find you?
30分钟都在谈论PowerPoint，真的应该在标题里加上PowerPoint。总之，也许我们之后会和你聊天，维托里奥。谢谢你来参加。我们会让你参加正式采访。谢谢你来参加。我很乐意。非常感谢。如果人们想雇你做培训，他们在哪里能找到你？
Yeah, so I have a link called Romeo. Dot Training, which is my, let's say, personal web page where I describe my services and you have a contact form there. But you can also find me on Twitter, LinkedIn, anywhere. I'd be super happy to chat with you. And that is Romeo like Romeo and Juliet, Romeo like the Shakespeare play. Dot training. No one's confused about Romeo, my guy.
是的，所以我有一个链接叫Romeo.Training，这是我的，让我们说，个人网页，我在那里描述我的服务，你可以在那里找到联系表。但你也可以在Twitter、LinkedIn上找到我，任何地方。我非常乐意和你聊天。那是Romeo，像罗密欧与朱丽叶，Romeo，像莎士比亚的戏剧。Dot training。没有人会对罗密欧感到困惑，伙计。
Anyways, have a good one. Be sure to check these show notes. either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
总之，祝你过得愉快。一定要查看这些节目简介，无论是在你的播客应用中还是在ADSPthepodcast.com上，获取我们在今天这一集中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢并祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是带有信息点缀的混乱。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。